quel plaisir et quel bonheur de vous
retrouver pour une nouvelle vidéo spider
man ça y est le trailer est enfin sorti
et la hype monte encore d'un cran en
vrai j'avais peur de ce qu'on allait
avoir vu la communication de sony ces
dernières semaines je me disais qu'on
avait peut-être avoir un trailer qui
dévoile le strict minimum et au final
banon je suis pas du tout déçu et il ya
même vraiment plein de choses à dire
donc voilà je suis je suis vraiment
content de partager ça avec vous
aujourd'hui sans plus attendre parts ont
analysé ce trailer le décrypter et bien
sûr émettre quelques petites théorie
mais avant ça je vous conseille bien
évidemment de vous abonner à la chaîne
si ce n'est pas encore déjà fait vous
êtes beaucoup à regarder les vidéos sans
être abonné on a déjà beaucoup parlé
spider man et je peux vous assurer qu'on
va continuer donc voilà commençons par
rapport au précédent teaser trailer nous
retrouvons la problématique du sort raté
par dr strange à cause des interférences
causées par peter cette fois ci on nous
explique qu en altérant l'espace temps
ils ont reçu certains visiteurs en
provenance de tous les univers alors ici
je pense qu'il ya déjà une première
magouilles car qu'est ce qu'il définit
exactement quand il dit tous les univers
nous savons que le concept de magie dans
le mc us se base sur les autres
dimensions et les autres univers par
exemple l'ancien était plus forte car
elle tirait son pouvoir de la dimension
noir est bien ici dans la logique
docteur strange désigneraient les autres
univers sur lequel il s'est basé pour
faire son fameux sort qui permettrait de
faire oublier qui est peter parker et du
coup cela explique la présence des
méchants des précédents films spider man
car strange aurait utilisé les univers
de the amazing spider man et sam raimi
pour corriger le sien c'est comme ça que
je le comprends néanmoins il ya un truc
qui me chiffonne car strange affirme que
chaque méchant moeurs face à spider man
et que c'est leur destin mais sauf que
le problème c'est que bâle l'homme sable
et le lézard contredit cette idée
puisque bas à temps l'univers de sam
raimi et du coup asio mezine il ne meurt
pas en fait donc voilà la possibilité
que certains méchants soit des variants
soient les mêmes méchant mais d'autres
univers bah c'est pas tant que ça à
exclure pour moi puisque si l'homme
sable est censé mourir face à spider man
et pareil pour le lézard c'est qu'il ne
viendrait pas des anciens films mais
d'univers équivalent bref vous allez
voir qu'au final il y aurait
possiblement un sens dans tout ça
d'ailleurs petite mention spéciale pour
électro qui a bien que louable et
ressemble beaucoup plus à ce qu'ils
étaient dans les comics il faut que nous
parlions de docteur octopus présenté
comme un hôte agoniste important et
principal dans le premier trailer
revenant de spider man 2 ici octavius
nous est montrée sous un autre angle sa
confrontation avec peter et directement
montré avec le reveal qu'il s'attaque
aux mauvais peter faisant référence à
toby maguire sauf qu'après ça sony nous
a montré qu que tu as vu ce serait
plutôt enclin à aider le spider man de
tom holland et c'est quelque chose de
tout à fait cohérent et pas du tout
anodin car parmi toute la panoplie de
super vilains de noé comme octave zus
est le seul à n'avoir jamais été
véritablement un vilain et n'a jamais
voulu détruire peter parker il était
même plutôt comme un mentor il a été
contrôlé par ses bras et plus que ça
encore il souhaite par dessus tout aider
l'humanité et non la détruire il ne veut
pas mourir comme un monstre octavius
parmi les sinistres est le seul à avoir
accepté sa mort dignement et la cause
est lui-même pour sauver l'humanité ce
qui impliquerait du coup que dans nos
héros mme ils seraient près du coup à
leur faire c'est déjà sa mentalité et ce
serait pourquoi il l'aiderait spider man
il a conscience qu'il est obligé de
mourir mais tout comme la symbolique de
spider man 2 il ne partira pas en tant
que monstres cela fait écho également à
la scène où il combat électro car
évidemment des autres sinister ne
seraient pas d'accord avec cette
décision puisque d'après strange ils
sont obligés de mourir car c'est leur
destin du coup bah ils combattent pour
leur vie en fait même si l'univers est
en danger et affecté à cause de ça
octavius est le seul à être prêts à
mourir pour les autres et c'est un point
clé pour le film et maintenant il faut
que nous parlions du bouffon vert il est
attendu pour être le vilain principal du
film et pour cause le trailer nous
révèle pas mal de choses à son égard
effectivement le bouffon vert est un
vilain particulier qui colle
parfaitement à la situation de nommer
comme une des grandes thématiques du
trailer et que peter va devoir faire des
choix il ne peut pas sauver tout le
monde et tout avoir ce dernier veut
sauver les sinister nous pouvons penser
que c'est par rapport à son expérience
façade lisse thériault qui l'a marqué
spider man n'est pas un héros qui tue et
vu les problèmes qu'il a eus après il
n'a peut être pas trop envie que cela
recommence mais notamment par rapport à
octave youth si ils aident peter sachant
qu'il va mourir peter voudrait
certainement changer cela et c'est là
que le bouffon vert entre en action
puisque là où octavius est prêt à mourir
pour l'humanité est bien le bouffon vert
c'est tout l'un verse et plus que ça
encore il est un vilain qui crée le
doute chez peter qui lui fait faire des
choix qui essayent de l'opposer à
l'humanité et c'est d'ailleurs très
cohérent par rapport au trailer nous
nous entendons la voie du bouffon vert
s'adressant directement à peter
puisqu'il lui dit que le monde
l'obligent à faire des choix qu'il n'a
pas envie de faire sous-entendant
derrière cela une manipulation pour que
peter agissent dans l'intérêt du bouffon
père otto pc gringo been sont vraiment
les deux antagonistes et plus iconique
de spider man et de par l'importance
qu'ils auront été donnés dans les
trailers on comprend très facilement que
ces deux personnages seront clairement
centraux dans le récit et puis même il
n'y a pas photo comparé à un électro ou
un homme sable ou encore un lézard voilà
il c'est pas le même level bon pour
continuer nous devons parler évidemment
d'andrew garfield et tobey maguire et
franchement il ya eu des dingues rien
dans ce trailer déjà en termes de
référence octavius mentionne tobey
maguire quand il fait face à peter
parker est également il ya une référence
à la scène de la mort de bouaine stacy
quand michel est en train de tomber que
peter essaye de la rattraper je pense
que cette référence est un résultat de
la thématique du choix lié à peter comme
dit dans le trailer il ne peut pas
sauver tout le monde et il va devoir
faire des choix et comme l'indiquent
titre du film pas de retour en arrière
possible
pas de retour à la maison donc si il
priorise les sinister à la place de
michel cette dernière mucha mais surtout
il faut parler du soit disant combat de
faim déjà je préfère le dire ici mais
normalement jamais un combat final
démontré dans un trailer car cela
dévoile trop de choses sur l'entièreté
du film ils ne vont pas révéler toutes
les surprises de noé home dans ce fameux
combat nous voyons peter face à electro
le lézard et l'homme sable en un contre
trois sauf qu on l'a tous remarqué la
position d'électro et celle du lézard
sont vraiment très étrange il ne semble
pas du tout visé le peter de tom holland
il ya clairement une manipulation ici
surtout que quand peter semble
s'échapper ou quitter le combat électro
semble n'en avoir rien à faire ils
continuent de combattre on ne sait pas
qui mais là où cela devient même drôle
c'est concernant le trailer brésilien
puisque dans ce dernier et ce n'est pas
un fake le lézard se prend un coup qui
vient de nulle part donc c'est que
quelqu'un a été cachée pour ne pas
apparaître dans le trailer et on sait
très bien de qui il s'agit de toute
façon c'est pas méchant le dire mais le
spider man de tom holland n'a pas les
toffes pour faire du 1 contre e3 et il
ya même même tobey maguire à l'époque en
un contre deux il galère de fouet au
final il a eu besoin de l'aide de harry
osborn bref je ne sais vraiment pas quoi
ajouter plus par rapport à cette scène
c'est vraiment trop flag en fait il ya
là tout est dit d'ailleurs par rapport
aux manipulations trailer il se pourrait
que michel soit sauvé par nd groupe au
final pour faire comme une rédemption
par rapport à la mort de gwen stacy où
il avait échoué nous pouvons d'ailleurs
aussi mentionné le vieux masque de
spiderman qui traînent dans le trailer
peut-être un oubli de sony en vrai je ne
saurais pas trop vous dire en tout cas
par rapport au trailer tout me laisse
porte à croire que nous aurions
un quatre contre quatre avec d'un côté
octopus du coup tom holland tobey
maguire et andrew garfield et de l'autre
côté du coup bas le bouffon vert
électros henman et le lézard mais du
coup qu'en est-il de doctor strange et
bien il se pourrait que ce soit le début
de multivers of madness la mort des
sinister semble résonner comme des
points absolue de leurs univers
respectifs
une thématique qui avaient été amenés
dans what if quand dr strange essaye de
sauver christine palmer alors que sa
mort était obligatoire pour faire de
strange ce qu'il est devenu étant donné
qu'il ne faut pas jouer avec la mort la
survie potentiel des sinister serait un
danger pour l'univers qui pourrait le
faire s'effondrer car cela ne respecte
pas les lois naturelles de l'univers et
cetera et cetera etc mais en vrai de
vrai les raisons sont quand même pas mal
flow derrière tout ça nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler dans une
prochaine vidéo mais strange cache
quelque chose là et ce quelque chose
explique notamment sa non présence face
aux sinister déjà c'est une excuse pour
pas qu'ils les combattre car il est trop
fort pour eux on va pas se mentir cela
fait comme endgame où il est occupé à
maintenir l'eau au lieu de le combattre
et puis surtout cela traduit que strange
est ailleurs en train d'agir pour
quelque chose de plus profond il a dit à
peter débrouille toi scooby doo est
scrap il lui a donné une boîte pour
enfermer les sinister et gré de sa
combinaison avec de la magie pour lui
faciliter la tâche enfin voilà écoutez
je pense qu'on va s'arrêter là en vrai
il ya vraiment plein plein de choses à
dire sur le trailer il ya encore
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de zones
d'ombré donc à vous de me dire si vous
aimeriez d'autres vidéos sur le sujet en
tout cas cela fait vraiment plaisir
d'avoir enfin de l'actus sur spider man
or rumeurs et or viol hic je suis très
heureux d'avoir pu vous partager ma
vision et mes idées concernant ce
trailer n'hésitez pas à partager vos
perceptions en commentaire c'est
toujours très intéressant à lire et puis
voilà n'oubliez pas le petit pouce bleus
à vous abonner c'est très important et
puis bah je vous renvoie vers mes
dernières vidéos concernant spider man
et cetera pour un aspect global de la
chose et puis bah que le lionheart soit
avec vous écoutez c'était targo rock
allez ciao tout
[Musique]